[Music]
all right chuck i got one for you
all righty i'm ready favorite one of my
favorite words
okay albedo all right now what language
is this
what the language the language of
science really
albedo okay first of all it sounds like
a scientist
not a scientist hey how you doing i'm
albedo perhaps you're familiar with my
equations
but now libido albedo albedo
so albedo is
a very precise measurement of
how reflective something is
real at a given wavelength but typically
we're just at any wavelength
so so for example if you have an
albedo of above an albedo can range from
zero to one
okay so think of it as a percentage so
zero percent to 100
so an albedo of 0.5
that means half the light
that hits it gets reflected gotcha
so what happens to the other half it's
absorbed absorbed
absorbed absorbed okay an albedo of a
hundred percent
is a mirror a mirror precisely
cool so nothing gets absorbed okay
and an albedo of zero means
a hundred percent of the light energy
gets absorbed and nothing gets reflected
black
back wow okay can that even exist
yeah it's called a black hole but um
no but also also um stars
have basically zero albedo but no one
thinks about it that way because they
are
generating light over there they're
radiating lights why would they be
yeah no no because you yeah so it turns
out and i will get into in this
explainer that these glowing stars out
there
they absorb all energy that hits it
and they manufacture their own energy to
come back out
but it's the absorption energy
the absorbent energy is not as
interesting to talk about right when it
is an energy generating source unto
itself right so let's see how albedo
affects us so so if
if you didn't have anthropologists
saying let us divide the world into
races
okay right if they really wanted to be
sort of scientific about it they could
just
have an albedo you just get to have an
albedo right because
yeah yeah that's a full spectrum right
right right that's so much
that's so much more specific there's
more arbitrary
designations that we give people based
on their skin color and their culture
yeah right because what we do is we say
everybody who has this right put them in
this one bin and we'll describe them all
that way okay and that way but if you
thought about
albedo from the beginning you'd realize
that the human species
fully populates the entire spectrum
the entire range of albedos okay they're
very highly reflective white people
they're very highly absorptive black
people right and so
uh dark-skinned people like so like
diamonds like german hansu
way down there very way down there okay
reflecting very little light
that hits him right and so this tells
you a lot of things
okay yeah so if you have very if you're
very fair-skinned you're reflecting
most of the sunlight that hits you right
even so
fair-skinned people are susceptible to
sunburn right
even though they're reflecting most of
the light that hits them
the little bit that gets through is
sufficient to do skin damage
right if darker colored skin you're
absorbing most of the light that hits
you
and you're not getting skin cancer right
so
the the role of melanin is extraordinary
in that regard
okay so but let's keep going um
the take a guess what the what the
albedo the moon is just take a guess you
see it at night
well i got to tell you it's pretty
bright but it's nowhere near as bright
as the sun
so well the sun gives off it's with the
sun it radiates it
albedo is a reflectivity that's what i'm
saying so it's just you know it's not a
mirror because it would be as bright as
the sun so i'm going to say
i'm going to say 5. 0.5 yeah 0.5 okay
so no no the albedo of the moon is
around 0.1
wow the moon is almost as
dark as the side wall tires on a car
wow that's just how bright the sun is
yes yes that's how bright the sun
is that it takes point one albedo and it
makes it look
like you look like and you can read by
the light of the moon
yes from earth that's right how romantic
i love
so so point one and so the moon is
basically
dark dark now so so when you
measure the date time temperature on the
moon that's kind of why it gets up to
the
hundreds of degrees right okay where is
it getting this temperature because it's
absorbing all that sunlight
wow if you're absorbing the energy
reflecting very
little there's the consequences your
temperature rises
that's cool okay so now i mean that's
hot okay
that's good that was good that was good
all right so now
let's look at the fashion industry
summertime
right okay are they rolling out their
black shirts and black dresses and black
blouses and black
no super light colors colors lighten
so that in the summer time where you
want to stay cool
even when you're outdoors here's this
sunlight
and you wear white clothes it reflects
the sunlight
and if you wore dark clothes not only
are you hot because the air is hot
you'll get hot because you're actively
absorbing sunlight
right and so that's it's it's not just a
fashion thing
it's a physics thing that if you want to
stay cooler in the summer
then you wear lighter colored clothes
unless you're it's the arctic
summer and it might warm up in the
antarctic it like might warm up to 28
degrees
you know in the in the heat of the
summer oh that's a hot day in the summer
huh
the hot days there you might want to
wear extra black to absorb as much
sunlight as you can
and so or you're just from new york
you just we could be strategic about the
color of the clothing
that you wear and then you put the
fashion element on it you can't wear
white after
uh labor day or whatever right but still
i i am strategic when i put on clothes
depending on the
weather forget the air temperature is
the sun out
do i want the sun's energy or do i not
and so i will factor all this in before
i step out the front door that day
wow okay so now go ahead what do you
think of the albedo the earth is
okay so i'm looking at the earth it's
mostly water
i'm gonna say that it's 0.3 that's
exactly 0.3
okay so well flight it fluctuates
it depends chuck's doing a happy dance
so so so the earth is is harder to
to give a single value to it because if
it happens to be cloudy on that side
that's facing the sun
clouds are white and they're highly
reflective so in that case the albedo is
higher than average if there are no
clouds and the oceans are pointing
towards the sun
oceans do reflect a lot of sunlight but
they're basically dark
and so you the average comes out to
about 0.3 cool
okay so that means 70
of the sun's energy that's hitting the
earth is absorbed
right wow and you know wow man you just
broke my heart when you said that
because
you know the fact is that we're trapping
heat
and then we got this heat coming in and
70 is already absorbed
and then we're trapping what has been
reflected we're trapping what's going to
be rejected
we're stupid as hell what is wrong with
us
what is wrong with us chuck i didn't
mean for you to blow a gasket on that
little bit of data there
it's like why he doing it exactly
so so you've got so that so 70
gets absorbed and basically stays here
unless it can re-radiate back
but that amount goes gets to the earth's
surface
it gets absorbed look at that and what
happens later is how much greenhouse
gases are there yeah
and this sort of thing all right so but
wait there's more
okay so i love it so earth is about
four times as wide as the moon is
moon is about two thousand miles across
earth is eight thousand miles in
diameter
so so four times away if you do the mass
earth
on the sky seen from the moon
is 16 times larger than the moon
in the sky as seen from earth that's
if if you do the math okay it must be so
great to stand on the moon
and so watch so watch so
full earth on the moon is not only 16
times larger
it is also three times more reflective
than the moon because it has an albedo
of 0.3
instead of 0.1 so that means
full earth seen from the moon is
three times 16
so is nearly 50 times brighter
brighter on the moon than full moon is
on earth
oh god the moon has it so much better
than we do
it's like you could sit there i mean to
watch an earth rise on the moon is just
like
so much better than what we get yeah
yeah so you talk about
people lunar lunar beings yeah lunar
beings
have it real good
moon people yes so yes and so they could
easily read by the light of the earth
if they needed to do so now the earth is
so bright that the crescent moon
right the crescent moon uh if you do the
geometry on this
if you see the crescent moon in the sky
you're looking towards
where the sun is and the entire
side of the earth that's lit by the sun
is facing that crescent moon
okay okay so what that means is
if you're in the darkened area of the
moon not the crescent so there's the
crescent in the rest of the moon
stand where it's not crescent the earth
is this
bright orb in the sky okay so now watch
the sunlight goes from the sun to the
earth
goes to you on the moon and you're
impressed that we're 50 times brighter
and it is so bright
on that darkened area of the moon that
it reflects back to earth
uh that's why you can see the outline
of the rest of the moon from the
crescent
have you seen this in the twilight sky
yes just about to say
that that happens you can't you the sun
isn't illuminating that there's no
reason
at all in this universe for that to be
visible to you
except that it's double reflecting earth
light oh that's amazing
that is really cool i mean that is just
that's amazing and it's called earth
shine
earth oh and i think it really should be
called moonshine
maybe that's me that's just me that's
just me but it's the
sun illuminating full earth illuminating
the darkened moon
coming back to earth and that's why
that's visible
that's that's you know that's great and
it's all about the albedo um
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna make
some moonshine and call it albedo
you know that's albito moonshine baby
when you when you wanna shine twice as
bright
count me in on that i want to be an
early investor on your moonshine albedo
uh and one last thing before we we land
this plane here
for the longest while people assumed
that the moon was the source of its own
light right
okay then you had to come up with
explanations for why it would go through
phases which was hard
but that was just assumed and it's
basically that's traceable back to
biblical genesis
you know god created the moon to light
the night and the
sun to light the day and no one
understood the geometry of what was
going on
it was just widely assumed that that
meant the moon was making its own light
so earthshine was unexplained
until leonardo da vinci my man and in
his notebooks which are all he's
left-handed and he writes backwards
and he's illustrates what he's talking
about and he's a brilliant artist
so he figures out because he saw where
the sun is where earth is
what must be illuminated what must not
he has a picture
i think it's in his codex likes like
sister
codex likes her which is these these
opuses of his writings
and in it you s he draws this
a ray of sunlight coming to the earth
going back to the moon and then coming
back to
earth wow and so he first figured it out
15th century
guy's a genius we got it soldered to it
that's amazing
there it is so that's albedo and you see
why i like the word it's fun to say it's
fun to think about and it's
it applies to so many things in this
world uh including earthshine which is
my new thing i love it
all right chuck that was great man that
was
albedo yes i i got an applause for that
one
thank you i'm telling you that was
really cool
man i'm gonna name my next son
okay all right and if you have a
daughter you're gonna name her
clairvoyant
right
and people then that's when um uh
child services comes to your house right
they say
yeah we're here to pick up albido and
clairvoyant because you certainly
are in no mental state to take care of
these kids
chuck i'm supposed to end the show here
all right um
where was i oh yes uh so that's yet
another explainer from star talk thanks
chuck for always being there
neil degrasse tyson keep looking
[Music]
you